from timcast.com quote political
persecution election interference at the
highest level in history Trump responds
to indictment will reportedly surrender
early next week never before no nation's
history has this been done the statement
from Trump let's pull it up let's read
it here we go if I can text kind of
small
he writes this is political persecution
and election interference the highest
level in history from the time I came
down the golden escalator Trump Tower
and even before I was sworn as sworn in
as your president of the United States
the radical left Democrats the enemy of
hard-working men and women of this
country have been engaged in a Witch
Hunt to destroy the make America great
again movement you remember it just like
I do Russia Russia Russia the Mueller
hoax Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine impeachment
hoax one impeachment hoax two the
illegal and unconstitutional Mar-A-Lago
raid and now this the Democrats have
lied cheated and stolen in their
obsession with trying to get Trump but
now they've done the unthinkable
indicting a completely innocent person
in an act of blatant election
interference never before in our
nation's history has this been done
the Democrats Have Cheated countless
times of the Decades including spying on
my campaign but weaponizing our justice
system to punish a political opponent
who just so happens to be a president of
the United States and by far the leading
Republican candidate for president has
never happened before ever Manhattan D.A
Alvin Bragg who was hand-picked and
funded by George Soros is a disgrace
rather than stopping the unprecedented
crime wave taking over New York City
he's doing Joe Budden's Dirty Work
ignoring the murders and burglaries and
assaults he should be focused on this is
how Bragg spends his time I believe this
Witch Hunt will backfire massively on
Joe Biden the American people realize
exactly what the radical left Democrats
are doing here everyone can see it so
our movement and our party UNIF United
United and strong will first defeat
Alvin Bragg and then we will defeat Joe
Biden and we are going to throw every
last one of these crooked Democrats out
of office so we can make America great
again
well very interesting
what do you think
they better be doing a really good job
at that office
um I think there's a lot of political
consideration that has to go into these
charges because it is
um it is a it's a really scary world
when your criminal justice system is
potentially interfering with an election
which is something that
um despite what some Americans think
that's all of our intelligence agencies
try really hard to avoid this exact
scenario where you might be indicting or
arresting or charging with crimes like
somebody that could be running for
president so I hope that whatever they
have I hope when these indictments are
unsealed some really solid stuff and
it's not just a whole bunch of like you
know Lucy whatever that ends up falling
apart what do you think about uh he
mentions Ukraine what do you think do
you remember the whole Ukraine gate
Fiasco impeachment
um Donald Trump quid pro quo yep I do
remember that yeah what are your
thoughts uh am I allowed to say the f
word uh after 15 seconds yeah I mean we
try to keep it the first 50 seconds they
demonetized yeah I think that's fine I'm
I'm okay with that impeachment if that's
what you're asking you you think Trump
committed a crime with absolutely you
want to elaborate I know it might be a
bit it's been long time it's been a
while but my understanding was that
Trump contacted Ukraine zielinski and he
was asking if there was wrongdoing done
by
um I think it was by Biden and finding
that prosecutor and if they had any
information about potential wrongdoings
that Hunter Biden or Joe Biden had been
involved in in Ukraine and in exchange
for that he wanted to withhold a that
was already congressionally approved to
Ukraine for that so what's wrong with
that like why is why is that was that a
problem
um legally or morally or both either or
whatever legally I believe it's because
I don't think the president has the
authority to withhold that Aid I don't
remember what the legal arguments were
on that um for the the moral part is our
precedent uh probably shouldn't be
asking other countries to investigate
like wrongdoings of political opponents
that's a really like Joe Biden wasn't
running for office at the time
um I mean why was he hold on I'm trying
to think of the timeline for this yeah
Joe Biden it was a year before he
announced
that was that was part of the
controversy that Joe Biden had not
announced he was running for office at
all no but hold on he might not have
announced it but like pretty sure most
people knew he was running like in the
early polls like if you looked at real
uh was it real clear progress if you
looked at a lot of the polling aggregate
sites like they were already polling
Biden he'd already been factored in
quite a while he might have announced
that he was going to run for office but
I'm pretty sure a lot of people were
expecting it I mean I mean that's just
speculative Media stuff so Trump isn't
actively investigating a political
opponent unless the argument is we all
secretly knew that was going to be the
case they were like Bernie Sanders was
still in the race there are a bunch of
other people at the time the controversy
was like why would Joe Biden there were
there were other Democrats that were
actually talking about running and it
wasn't Joe Biden he announced late he
did announce late but he was still
factored into the polls really early
because a lot of people thought he was
going to run the question is though is
that do we want the president contacting
other even if he's not running he is the
vice president did the same thing is
that if the vice president was I think
any time you're reaching out like let's
ask if we pull back on a micro level why
is Trump asking this information does he
genuinely think that there's been some
grave wrongdoing done by the bidens that
needs to be corrected for yeah and if so
why isn't he asking our intelligence
agencies for information about this why
is he going to another country and
asking I mean I don't we it's we're the
five I spy club we do that all the time
we don't do that all the time going to
another leader and saying hey I need you
to get dirt on a potential political
opponent because I think there's
something like he wasn't a political
opponent and he is a bullet even if he
was the vice president of the former
opposite party guy that he just um as he
came into office what do you mean he's
some kind of political opponent right
and even if he's even if he wasn't
directly running yet like I would argue
any if he was asking this over like AOC
for instance Trump I would say that it's
similar Trump didn't go to the president
of Ukraine and say I got this political
opponent I need dirt on he said what's
up with this video of Joe Biden
threatening to withhold congressionally
approved Aid unless you take action on
his behalf and the president of Ukraine
was like I'm not sure he was well can
you look into that I want to know what
that's about it wasn't just can you look
into that it was if if you don't find
what I need I might withhold a that's
already been congressionally approved
for you and that was the issue if he was
just asking questions we wouldn't be
having the conversation he wasn't
impeached right so this is the point
that I'm getting at when when this
started and Donald Trump asked about
this specifically because there was a
viral video video of Joe Biden outright
admitting to threatening to withhold
congressionally approved Aid unless a
prosecutor got fired you had Joe Biden
breaking the law sure so there was a
video of Joe Biden on stage making the
claim slash joke on stage where he's
saying I told him you don't do it you're
not going to blah blah blah blah blah
but in terms of him like well but in
terms of there actually being a serious
offer on the table where he was like
threatening to withhold Aid I'm not even
sure if that was ever the case it would
have that one statement that he was made
Victory number one signed a sworn
affidavit that is what happened number
one number two the impetus for Shogun
being removed from Ukraine was not to
get some kind of political dirt on on an
opponent it was a completely different
scenario this is a prosecutor that all
of Europe and and over half of Ukraine
wanted fired that the United States was
acting on behalf of the western world
and trying to pressure this prosecutor
out because of his lack of Prosecuting
corruption in the country that's a
totally different thing than I
threatened to withhold aid from this guy
because he's not giving me dirt on
potential political opponents so why is
it that the guy who was being
investigated my club
returned to the country he had fled when
shokun was was investigating him and
then after Joe Biden got choking removed
zlachevski returned to the country to
begin working on bursma again
why did he return to the country so so I
could have been for any numbers I'm not
sure right so the argument from the
Democrats the specific corruption that
wasn't being prosecuted referring to is
the prosecution of Michaela zlachevsky
the the founder of barisma okay and the
argument they made was he wasn't
investigating him that was the problem
and then Joe Biden says and we we got we
got him out and then they put in someone
solid the only issue is when shoken had
about a dozen active investigations into
barisma and slachevsky zlachevsky fled
the country they tried they froze his
account when Biden came in and got the
prosecutor fired zlachevsky safely
returned to Ukraine without fear of
criminal prosecution When Donald Trump
made that phone call zlachevsky fled
again
so it sounds more like it's like so uh
you've got Hunter Biden on the board of
barisma you've got a former CIA director
on the board of barisma and zlachevsky
the founder and shokin was invested he
had 12 different and active around 12 to
14. all of the investigations into
barisma were dead no they won't that's
not true it was wrong absolutely true
completely they were only revived one
month before shokun was forced out every
single one of those probes was
completely dead that that's that's wrong
you can Google and look for it if you
want so I'm citing Matt taibi oh God
right and if you don't if you don't want
to trust the journalist or whatever or
like any actual like article not a tweet
like like anything actually I'm talking
about an article that he wrote breaking
down what happened with Ukraine and his
investigation into and this is from like
20s okay so your claim is that um the
probes into barismo never went cold and
never die that they were active the
entire time they they were active they
entered right okay my understanding is
that those probes were all cold and all
dead and it was part of the world before
nice and cold it's the same thing they
were being actively worked on so there
were probes that nobody was doing
anything with them until it was one
month before shokun was actually ousted
that there was some progress started to
be made so the question that that's a
very difficult question to get into the
fact is there were active investigations
well but that's kind of the meat of what
we're talking about right well so it's
kind of important to settle the fact of
the matter of that yeah were there 12
investigations yes or no they're I know
that there were investigations open for
a couple years but my understanding is
that it's all open it's not all that
matters they were dead investigations
that's what I read that was reported
right my point is this but that's pretty
important because if they're being
actively investigated then that
obviously changes a little bit the story
that we're telling you so did shoken
have investigations into into barisma
and slachevsky yes he had about a dozen
but whether or not live or dead is that
important you don't think so did
zlachevski flee the country while these
were on the books
yes he did I don't know when shokin was
removed and the and the investigations
were officially stricken zlachevsky
returns so do you think that there are
criminal wrongdoings that he's done that
he's not being prosecuted for
what I think is that the United States
is in in an energy crisis in a war with
Eastern Powers the United States has
been trying to get a pipeline for
natural gas called the cutter turkey
pipeline into Europe but Syria said no
Syria destabilizes for whatever reason
we want to run that pipeline through
Syria through turkey into Europe to
offset the gas Prime Gas Monopoly Russia
runs natural gas into Europe through
Ukraine through gas prom it's about 20
percent it's massively powerful for them
and allows them to control prices the
United States has interests in setting
up an energy company to offset that
Monopoly hence barisma Hunter Biden's on
the board probably for these reasons a
former CIA director probably for the
Prisma one of the smaller gas companies
in that country and absolutely and it
seems like the U.S was trying to compete
with Russia to get cheaper gas to Europe
and the argument made was that Europe
was constrained by high gas prices from
Russia and that we wanted the European
economy to be bolstered and grow faster
to compete with China but Russia was
basically keeping us pinned down sure
this is nice conjecture but like is
there anything back in up any of this
aside from like this is all the official
reporting what do you mean by official
reporting so there's official reporting
that we should have choken because we
wanted to bolster U.S interests that's
the only speculation I have I'm saying
based on the facts it seems to me the
issue was shoken did have investigations
into Prisma which was a problem for U.S
interests not because of corruption but
because we're it's a it's more of a war
front it's more of a do you think do you
think that Shogun was a corrupt
prosecutor no okay why did all of Europe
and a lot of Ukraine hate him because
Europe wants cheap gas
shoken was impeding that it's that issue
of corruption it's an issue of
conflicting and how so active
investigations into barisma are impeding
U.S interests in competing with gas
Charisma isn't even the largest gas
player in that country though that's not
the point we didn't we don't have the
cutter turkey pipeline into Ukraine
because Syria blocked it so you have a
multi-front effort going back to I think
like the 2000s to get cheaper natural
gas into Europe so of course they're not
going to like anybody who's got Eastern
allegiances it's it's possible that with
Ukraine you had in the eastern part of
the country more pro-russia sentiment
with yanakovich you had more pro-russia
sentiment and you had government
officials that were like look we are not
just pro-west of course then he gets
ousted there's there's a there's unrest
uh I can't what do you mean for
yanakovich though Yanukovych was
standing alone with that pro-russian
status though that wasn't all the
government officials that was part of
the reasons why people were so upset
with yanakovich was because right he was
trying to to push for Russia in
opposition to what their Parliament was
even pushing that's what I'm saying and
so there's probably he wasn't the only
person that sent was fairly split but
was leaning towards the EU had been
voted on by their Parliament like to
favor the EU that was what the right is
for and so the the way I see it is there
are probably elements of that government
that were more favorable to Russia which
is why Europe doesn't like them the the
people ukrainians who want to be a part
of the EU members of the EU who want
Ukraine to join because they want more
control over natural gas of course
naturally would oppose anybody who is
siding with Russia do you think that
Ukraine was a corrupt country prior to
2014 yes okay I mean it's do you think
so when so for all of Europe and for
everybody complaining about the
corruption
um and stuff relating to shoken you
think that all of that was BS and they
just didn't like him because he was
preventing their cheap oil or cheap gas
say that one more time you think that
all of the upsettedness that people
across Europe and Ukraine had with
shoken had nothing to do with any of the
corruption in the country or lack of
pressuring because like that's the
official story that's given it seems to
be like pretty consistent throughout
like I can only I can only speak on a
surface level about this one particular
issue because I don't know the inner
workings of all of Ukrainian politics
okay but what I do know is there's been
a tremendous effort by Western forces
leading to outright physical military
conflict to get natural gas into Europe
to offset Russia's control of gas prices
naturally it seems like these things are
related speculative the facts are the
U.S went to Syria and said can we build
the cutter turkey pipeline Syria
literally said the United States that
would be bad for our Ally Russia so we
will not allow it
for fortunately for us for whatever
reason Syria falls into Civil War and we
just happen to oppose the guy who denied
that I don't think the whole reason for
opposing it has to do with gas but it's
convenient for us nonetheless we weren't
able to do it and to make it worse Iran
wanted to tap the same natural gas field
and send the gas through Iraq and turkey
into Europe to strengthen Russia's
control of energy
so the the argument was the EU is trying
to grow and become a unified block to
compete with the growth of China and
Russia was basically impeding us because
Russia wants to be their own big dog
right sure let's so
um man if you ever wanted to re revisit
a detailed breakdown of this you'd be
interested to do a little bit of reading
prior to this but let's say let's say
hypothetically I grant you all of that
why didn't Trump say any of that Trump
doesn't know what the what the hell is
going on okay so then Trump's
investigation into so the impetus this
whole conversation bro okay so yeah so
the impetus for this whole conversation
of like Trump pressuring them to find
out if any wrongdos happened had nothing
to do with anything you've just laid out
it was just having to do with Hunter
Biden and Joe Biden it had to do with
him seeing a video and then seeing
people and post memes probably to be
completely honest it was Tucker Carlson
sure who said something but it was a
little bit more than just asking
questions because if he was just curious
I don't think that the the question of
Aid being withheld would have ever been
brought up in that conversation so
clearly there was a little bit you're
saying that Biden wasn't seen as a
political opponent at all but if that
was the case I don't know why Trump
would go so far to try to solicit
information from the Ukrainian
government such that he would withhold
Aid or threaten to withhold Aid in
exchange for some information about him
you know whether it seems like a random
politician to Target like why would he
be so dead set on getting information
about fights and Democrats they were
calling him a Russian spy
I think there's a little bit I think it
has to be a little bit more than that
Revenge to throw away I mean you can
think that but I'm not even I'm not I
don't even care all that much about the
speculation as to why he did it right
sure if you want to argue well I think
that's probably one of the most
important parts that is the most
important part is why he did it but you
guys have a few assumptions to get to
that point
specifically with respect to a political
opponent I'm making assumptions I feel
like there's a lot more assumptions they
made on your end that he was just
genuinely interested in what Joe Biden
had said and was threatening to withhold
a because he wanted a legitimate
investigation of the firing of a
prosecutor
I mean I feel like it's really
legitimate what we know is that he said
what's going on with this video I want
to see some action on this or else right
I feel like there was a little bit more
said than that but I don't Works in a
long time well I'm just I'm just trying
I'm trying to paraphrase paraphrase sure
but I feel like the the specific request
he was making for information are
probably pretty important I could look
up exactly what the charges are alleged
but it's been a while but so I guess the
reason I bring it up is not to just
debate Trump or whatever but but to ask
the question of
should we indict Joe Biden for doing the
same thing I don't believe Joe Biden did
the same thing though the request and
who it was on behalf of was Far
different than but Joe Biden does not
have the authority to threaten to
withhold congratulations I don't know if
Joe Biden actually threatened to
withhold Aid before that put it on
camera that he did he said he said
something on camera that I don't know
literally said on camera I told him that
if you don't fire the prosecutor
knocking the billion dollars and he said
you don't have the authority to do that
I said call the president ask him see
what he says well son of a six
hours later he's fired Trump also said
on camera they could shoot somebody on
6th Street and not get arrested for it
but that's different from admitting to
the committed crimes I don't know if
Biden admitted to a crime there or if he
was just talking Biden also was in
front of an audience saying that he had
what like 170 IQ and graduated from
Harvard Law or something right he
obviously didn't do that right so I
don't know when Biden is on stage like
oh I told him I was going to whistle I
don't know if he's just like you know he
got his big boy pants on he's talking
he actually did do that and he
didn't have the authority to do it and
it was on behalf of some Salvage mode or
whatever then yeah I think there should
obviously be an investigation or
something the fact that there's never
been an official statement confirming
that there's never been any um aside
from the Ukrainian officials confirming
that and that maybe there should be
everything relating to that yeah but
every time Republicans say there should
be and they go and look they find
nothing okay but whether it's Benghazi
whether it's Hillary's emails whether
it's uh
no the Hillary's email stuff is was
there like that's that's not even we
don't know if Hillary Clinton gave a
command to delete stuff that should have
been deleted to impede an investigation
we don't know that information which is
what the charge would have been for sure
sure we know that she had a server with
35 000 emails on it we know that there's
staff smashed hammers we know that um
one of our staffers I guess he went on
Reddit and he said how can I purge
emails with someone's name on it or
something like that sure and like I
think didn't he get charged or something
I don't know I think it was granted
immunity in exchange for information
yeah yeah that's crazy right I remember
when that happened like some dude on
Reddit found the account and they were
like I think this guy worked sure but
the crime that we were looking for was
whether or not Hillary Clinton ordered
classified emails to be deleted which
doesn't seem like that was we spent a
whole lot of time talking about that and
for all the complaining that we do about
a judge indicting Trump or intelligence
agencies interfering in elections Comey
coming out of making the statements that
he did about Hillary Clinton were not
only unprecedented but also potentially
election altering too so do you think
Barack Obama ordering a drone strike
that killed an American citizen warrants
an investigation of that
um there might have already been an
investigation I don't know what the the
vetting process inside of orders from
the government like whether whether
there was or wasn't do you think there
should have been
um yeah there probably always should be
when there's collateral damage didn't it
happen um was it in Afghanistan or
Pakistan wasn't there a hospital that we
accidentally bombed like a year and a
half ago I think probably I think like
20 or 30 people died and it was all
civilians like yeah anytime something
that happens there should obviously be
some type of oversight and but that's
different between like there needs to be
a criminal charge for an intentionally
destructive act done right do you agree
that there's a world of difference
between
um Biden ordered an American citizen
killed overseas versus American citizen
dies as a result of collateral damage
from a drone strike those two things are
Worlds Apart right well the added
context is we're not at war with this
country and it doesn't matter so even if
we aren't the country there's still
Worlds Apart right
so we'll slow down for a second sure my
question is very simply if we're not to
the president does not extend to bombing
any random country well it seems like
that's not where we're at legally right
now right I think it's not it's where
we're it's not where we're at because
the American people don't do anything
about it did we vote in Congress to bomb
the Syrian airport when Trump returned
fire for whatever gas attacks no but I
think there's something different to an
active war zone we do have troops on the
ground in and I don't agree with Syria
we have we have ground troops we have we
haven't declared a war since since World
War II I don't but we didn't even have a
UA uh uh yeah I don't agree with Trump's
firing I'm just saying that like like if
an American citizen even would have died
on the base yeah I'm just saying that
we're not voting for war in these areas
right we're still bombing them so it
seems like when you if you're asking me
a moral question versus a legal question
those are two different things if you're
asking me legally it seems like that
seems to be that the president can
indeed order drone strikes on place that
we're not at war with that seems to be
where we're at legally right now morally
should he be able to I don't know I
don't know what the justification is for
that thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time